And we can, we just all agree. That's back in 2020,
which is still when we're filming this,
by the way that my little POG champ was the worst meeting.
Can we just, can we just agree? I don't know what meme of the year was,
but that was, it was definitely not that it was definitely not that meme.
I should say that.
I don't know that meme kind of came out of nowhere and two,
it died so fast.
And I'm so glad that it was animated so that the poor person who voiced it
didn't get a full literary steroid, as you imagined,
that was like a person on Tik TOK. It'd be like, Oh my God, am I guaranteed?
There's like a number of like girls who went on to take talk.
It did like the whole voice. Of course. I'm not gonna look. Have you had,
have you had like take talks of people voicing over your videos? Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. So she went and did a lot of like anime character stuff. Oh yeah, yeah.
Loads. And they fully dress up in costume.
I've heard people doing that of just like me talking like normally,
like they would take a segment of me from like an, so you just get a fandom.
Yeah. That's just a fandom extra step.
Which where it's like someone took like really old audio of me and like an
answer me, same part where I'm just answering a question normally.
And then just like voicing over and acting over. I was like, I mean, come on.
There's lots of other like audio clips you could have taken.
That's a little more interesting. Right, right. Do you have a,
do you have any people like, uh, impersonating your voice? I get that a lot.
I mean, yeah, but that's cause you have a distinct voice,
I guess I don't exactly have a distinct voice. There's a few videos out there.
If people like, like, I think I mentioned this before the podcast, right?
They like go around on discord. [inaudible] the reaction.
I don't have crazy fans like you and what they do.
They just do like the most broken English accent.
[inaudible] hello, governor like a terrible, a British accent.
Doesn't sound always a deep voice.
Just doesn't even sound remotely like a British accent.
[inaudible] so your dog via video, this is [inaudible]
there's there's like they'll they'll like do yeah, exactly.
So they'll people in post next, Sebastian,
but not the actual Sebastian that I'm posting it. Like my Sebastian,
Sebastian there'll be like in the American accent.
I how to fight I do this because I'm so ingrained to do some British.
It'd be like, cause you know,
like Sebastian's catch phrase is simply one hell of a Butler, right.
There'd be like, I'm simply one hell of a Butler. And it was like, awful.
She was sound like, like half English, half American attempt. And it's like,
what? And um, that was a diff that was like layered. Like, yeah.
I was like, how do I break a British person,
person eating an American person, impersonating a British person.
Like I would hear these, I'd hear these voices that they would do. And I'm like,
there's no way they're going to believe that. And then the moment they do it,
they're like, Oh God. And I'm like, what? This is me.
And then there was someone who, well, he went on like voice acting websites,
trying to be me called it's Connor or something. It's Connor.
And they would go around making references to my videos.
Like I referenced myself. Like I go around and be like, Oh yes.
Remember that time I was Sebastian, good times. Like, references themselves.
That's that's some like, tell me why. You know what I mean?
Like who actually does, like, it's the only thing you had. Right? It's like,
I've made it now. I'm done making new stuff.
I'm just going to reference myself until I'm in time.
I like what people like shoot, see dog. Yeah. He said the thing.
So it must be him. It infuriates me to death because I'm like,
if this is all it takes to get you to believe this is me.
I hope your credit card gets stolen. Just serve it.
Like you had a comment if you think that's bad. Yeah, no, no. Seriously.
Like I haven't had people posting any of my voice, but I've had people like,
you know, kind of trying to do it by just speaking in a Australian accent.
Yeah. And sometimes the voice is totally not me.
It's a completely different voice.
But because they're speaking in like a semi light oil Australia,
it's pretty fun. How light, how much room people would be. Yeah.
I've not seen any tech talks,
but I've had exactly the same like comments of like some random YouTube who like
is reviewing anime clips or something in a slight British accent.
And they're like, Oh my God, it's gig. I'm not just that.
The thing that annoys me no more actually is not on YouTube or ticked off.
But it's on Twitter where anyone apparently anyone Southeast Asian who posts
like a selfie now who's also into anime. It's just like, Oh my God,
you look like, Gignac you do? Oh my God. I have so many photos of people.
Like just like random Indian celebrities. And people are just like,
yo Joey, like I have a go.
My sister even sent me one. It was like, she found like on TV,
there was this like a Bollywood like movie or I guess like would show that they
were like promoting on an ad or something.
And apparently like one of the dudes just straight up,
like apparently looked like me. And I'm like,
it's just the Brown man with like a BA like that doesn't make
apparently every Brown man with a is me. Yeah. I get that with white dudes.
Like every white dude with a, I don't take talk. It's like,
for some reason they say, I looked like Cedar. I'm like, what the is there?
Like, is there like any that kind of like, uh, like,
Oh that you look like so-and-so person has been kind of flattering. Uh,
I've only had one example of that. And that's when people said that,
I looked like, uh, what was it? A crackdown, Jason mama.
And like, Oh, you look like Jason Mamoa if he didn't work out.
And I was like, yeah, y'all take that. Jason Mamoa was good luck.
It's kind of like Benedict Cumberbatch ones, but right, right.
I used to have like really big, like a curly hat that looked similar to him,
joked that I was like him and uncle. Cause I was also like British. Yeah.
Parents are British to Joe.
[inaudible] he's a British man. Therefore he looks like better than it.
I was like, no, I don't. I don't look like that. there now. He's nice. He's fun.
We like it. We like it. We have fun. Yeah. One got I I, I dunno.
It's two distinct cause like no,
nobody really knows anything about Southeast Asia.
So now it's just like F it's like w with like the new,
just like Japanese or Chinese people right now.
Cause now they're like Chinese and like Japanese culture has been more like,
and Koreans have been like more globalized, like Southeast Asians.
I just sit here in our own corner being like, Oh, you know,
there's more than like one country here as well, guys. You know,
it it's gone from like,
I can't tell the difference between Japanese Koreans and Chinese.
I can't tell the difference between Thai Phillip.
[inaudible] I can feel called out
like half the memes on like our subreddit.
It's just like a different white person with a bed. And it's just like,
Oh my goodness, hold on. It's a monkey brain.
I got no beard now actually. Well, I mean, I just shaved it like two days ago.
Oh the amount of memes though, of like you with baby face is hilarious. Yeah.
I do look like a ten-year-old without a beard, someone posted on the subreddit,
this like old photo of me in a suit. Have you guys seen? I was like, what?
Why, how did they find that it's on Google. It's on my Instagram. I thought,
yeah. Like the second ever photo was like six years old or something.
There's a baby. I know. I was like, how old was I? Like 20?
Maybe you just looked at the kind of kid who was like, get me out of here. Yeah,
I did. Yeah. I, I regret it. Not a good funnel.